[Music]
all right my name's johnny knoxville
welcome to the doctor i'm getting oh i'm
but i'm sorry dude
it was the worst pain ever explain what
the game is it's called the dum-dum game
and uh you get a good question that it's
kind of tricky but and then if you don't
get it right
boom they were on a fourth grade level
you know tricky questions
who played the piano on elton john's
album madman across the water
um
my favorite part of that bit though is
aaron is so smug like poopy's are
struggling to answer a question
what's his name oh yeah that's why i
accidentally missed the button once
everyone's questions like what continent
is africa on
[Laughter]
africa yeah all right
the world waited for what felt like
forever
then
[Applause]
we waited longer
but this february
we promise it's gonna be the gnarliest
[ __ ]
ever
the wait is over
hello i'm johnny knoxville welcome to
jackie
if you're gonna be dumb you gotta be
tough
when you get knocked down
if they trust us to go to the bathroom
they're less intelligent than i thought
[Music]
you're still blowing people up as if
life's not hard enough this guy's one
badass dude
oh man i'm on jackass is it texas rat
snake venomous
francis hits harder than any heavyweight
in the mma i told aaron it was a
lightweight
[Music]
what's the worst that could happen
[Music]
you said it wasn't gonna feel like
anything
i just need you to like sit with my
grandpa just make sure he doesn't smoke
a bunch of nasa scientists right now can
i get a cold
will you make him an actual coffee
stephanie here i may do another one
it's got to be over dude i think we're
all the way finished with fruit
stick or fork in it
[Music]
bye